the the role of the NHS Power view body
makes recommendations to the Prime
Minister Secretary of State for Health
and Social care here in England the
first minister in Scotland the first
minister in Wales and the minister of
Health in Northern Ireland on all staff
under the agenda for change
program and employed in the NHS there is
a separate how everybody looks at
doctors and dentists so I just want to
make clear to those watching that that
is what the nhsprb
is about obviously there are wider
issues in Workforce at the moment across
the NHS and they're not all the
responsibility of our guests today so
just before we introduce them I think
one of our members Rachel maskel wanted
to to put a declaration on the record
I'm a member of United Union and the GMB
and I was a former head of Health at
unite and have submitted evidence
including all evidence the pay-per-view
body great thank you very much thank you
so we have Philippa heard with us who's
chair of the NHS pay review body and we
have David fry who's the director of
office of Manpower economics at the
department of a business energy and
Industrial strategy thank you so much to
both of you for making time coming in to
speak to the select committee this
morning I know there's a lot of interest
in this session outside and inside
Parliament so we really appreciate your
time
um Philip if I may start with yourself
as chair could what do you think the
greatest misunderstanding is about the
NHS pay of your body is it about its
independent isn't what it can cannot do
what's the greatest misunderstanding
um
I'm here please do for the pay review
body and I hope the session is useful to
the um to the committee
um you'll be aware that this is my last
of
um six years as chair of the pay for
your body so in the first three years
our reports focused on commentary on a
three-year deal that was made between
the parties and we returned to making
recommendations
um uh in um
2021 and 2022 and we're currently in the
process of our work for a report for
um so that's probably helpful context
and we have remits as you say from the
UK government in respect of the NHS in
England and from uh Wales and Northern
Ireland
um
what what we essentially do we do we do
three things we
um we produce a body of evidence I
suppose a curated body which is useful
over time
which details a full range of analysis
of the NHS Workforce particularly as
regards to pay but all the factors that
relate to pay we make recommendations in
any one specific year about an award in
that year
and then we also
um do our best
to inform government thinking about pay
and the the case for investment in pay
in the longer term
um so I think that's it's probably
um important for us that those three
quite separate things are well
understood
you've probably heard your name in your
organization being quoted talked about
discussed on the media a lot over the
course of the Christmas and New Year
holiday period in particular and since
and I'm sure you have had many phone
calls asking you to go on and and take
part in that but but what what have you
heard on the on the radio any discussion
about the NHS pay everybody that you've
thought no I'm sorry that's just that's
just plain wrong
we we set out our recommendations in
quite a lot of detail huge detail
actually probably
um in our report
um and
um and so there are there are obviously
occasions when I think I do wonder if
you've read the report
um uh and um and so
um
I think uh yeah one one of our my wishes
those are the last couple of months is
that the people making the commentary
had had read the report
interesting well for the record I have
read your last report it's 188 Pages
I've made this case to many journalists
over the course of the last few months
that have you uh they never quite answer
but anyway just just as a follow-up from
me so given that the joint NHS trade
unions have written to the Secretary of
State and written to you in the last few
weeks just ahead of the deadline for
submission of evidence to this year's
round basically saying that they're
boycotting this year's pay review
we've got a major problem haven't we
um
have said they are
not they have
put
material in the public domain on which
we will be able to draw
um some unions are taking part
okay okay so so who who is taking part
well
um those unions have chosen not to put
the evidence of public domain yet but we
have had evidence from some unions the
other way in which we
um uh we we listen to the voice of stuff
you'll be aware that um one of the
things we do is visit a wide range of
NHS settings so acute Community settings
um and when we do that
um so you know each visit and we we
visit uh in Northern Ireland Wales and
England uh we talked to staff at every
level in the organization so we have
small focus groups
um clinical and non-clinical
um at all pay bands so we have in-depth
discussions with staff and they tell us
how they feel about their work and about
their pay
um so we we do get a fair amount of good
quality input from from staff so you get
the wider context because of course a
lot of the
people who we've heard talking about the
industrial action over recent weeks have
sort of said look yes it's about pay but
it's about much wider than that and you
get that context I just wonder because I
said at the outset which I think is
important context for for viewers that
you know the doctors the dentists and
obviously you know the junior doctors
are currently waiting on the outcome of
their ballot
um and you're not responsible for that
for their payroll but do you talk to
them because obviously they're part of
that Health economy in a hospital when
you go and visit it and therefore they
will have a view on the agenda for
change pay rates and how that impacts on
their ability to do their jobs
um you'll be aware that doctors and
dentists and um NHS and the gender for
change Pace mind handle quite separately
and we don't talk to doctors now we do
talk to the senior leadership team
um in each of the um hospitals and
Healthcare settings we go to because we
want to understand their view about
Recruitment and Retention motivation of
morale and and what's happening to
um to their staff and and you're right
staff tell us about a broad range of
challenges
um but our job is pay and so we do try
and focus the conversation on that
all right we'll come back to some of
these later on but we're going to go
around the around the table if that's
okay so first up is Paul blomfield yes
sure
um and thanks very much for spending
time with us this morning I guess
everybody recognizes what a challenging
um job you've got part of that challenge
I guess is how you
balance the different considerations
that you're charged with bearing in mind
and there are clearly several I mean
taking three recruitments and retention
the funds available
the government's inflation Target
squaring that Circle in reaching a
recommendation sounds pretty impossible
in many ways how do you balance those
different objectives
um
I wonder if it's helpful to talk a
little bit about process by which we do
that because we don't just do it in one
conversation the whole process is about
balancing those objectives is it worth
testing that so as I've talked about our
visits so um it starts with the visits
which are usually
um in the kind of late summer autumn of
the years we've just finished our visits
for this year
um and um then we tend to get a remit
letter
um if I can it's worth talking a little
about the timing of the remit letters
but maybe we can come on to that later
but we get a remit letter this year it
came in late November at that point
um we make requests for evidence from
the parties to our report so that's the
government employers staff side
and we also start collecting our own
evidence so we look very widely
at all the commentators for our own
economic evidence
um that evidence comes in over a period
of a few weeks we do what we can ahead
of the remit letter to socialize what
we're going to need and so people are
prepared
um to give some need
um we then assess that evidence together
so we all work together and you'll write
some of these things are very difficult
um to find an answer that comfortably
reconciles some some very very difficult
things
um we then have a process of all
evidence and that's our opportunity to
talk
um with and virtually maybe tourism
sessions
um to talk
um about in detail about similar
elements of the evidence by that point
usually the parties have seen each
other's evidence they may have views on
each other's evidence and so that
process goes into some detail
um and they're also at that point
sometimes we have specific questions
that we decide we want to ask all
parties in the same way so last year for
example we asked about the bottom of Pay
Band to and minimum wage national living
wage considerations as a question for
all parties because we felt it was an
area
um for development
when we've completed all of that and we
have a lot of data and a lot of evidence
then we work to to develop the key
themes the key things that we think
impact on the report
and we aim to reach consensus about
about the um both the data as I said are
the three things we do the data the data
picture the complete picture about a
number and about the the other
considerations we think are important in
the medium term
that's the process by which we do it
thanks very much for that it's I guess
understanding how that
Works in kind of finishing the judgments
um
and how far
um you know the government
as a critical stakeholder in that entire
process
um shakes thinking I mean I'm minded to
kind of reference the uh letter that you
got from the then Secretary of State
kicking off the
2022-23 pay round in which he said it's
vital that planned Workforce growth is
Affordable and within the budgets set
and in this third paragraph went on to
emphasize we must ensure the
affordability of a pay award that's a
pretty clear steer isn't it how far how
do you respond to that but it's it's one
of our considerations but you'll be
aware that in the two recommendations
that that we've done recently we
recommended more than the government
said they could afford
so in 2020 they said they could afford
one percent and we recommended three
um and in 2022 they said they could they
could afford two percent but had set
aside another one percent of the
contingency and we recommended 4.8 so it
is a consideration it's an important
consideration but
there are others that balance it and we
set out very clearly our real concerns
about Recruitment and Retention which we
felt meant that
they were a real counter to that
affordability
thank you and of course it's worth
saying isn't it that the government can
accept your report uh in full without
funding it in full so it could accept
your recommendation and say to the
department that we accepted in full but
you then have to fund it from existing
budgets which is indeed what happened
here exactly okay Paul Bristow thank you
chair
um what if I could just direct your or
ask you a little bit about what some
people have said about
um your role and what you do so um
Sharon Graham the General Secretary of
unite said that your processes have
degenerated into fast that you are long
past your sell by date and that you're a
willing partner in working to the
government's pay cuts agenda do you
think that's fair
return to David actually
[Laughter]
because I think that it's probably right
that the person who looks at all the
pair review bodies
um comments on on what issues of
um of Independence okay thank you
Philippa and just to say so so I'm the
director of the ime and we provide the
secretary Act of the eight public sector
pay review buddy so that includes the
nurses and then other groups such as
teachers armed forces and the like
and and together the pay review bodies
influence the pay of about 2.2 million
public sector workers so it's about 45
percent of the of the uh public sector
um and
the review bodies have been around quite
a while so the the NHS report the last
one was the 35th report
and the review bodies have endured over
time and different ones have been
created by different governments
um and you know the most recent one
being I think 2014 when the police
review body was was created so um you
know from my sense
um you know they they must be doing
something that's that's right and
helping things work forward he wouldn't
say it's fair to say that you're a
willing partner in working to the
government's pay cuts agenda well and
what I was going to say is I think that
you know the review body is in that
tricky position it is it's between the
unions and between uh government but but
the the members of the review buddy are
all in uh appointed independently it's
not fair so I I think I think that you
know it's it's the different parties
will have their views and they and they
will say them you know as the chair said
over over Christmas we saw lots of views
I won't embarrass it anymore by
repeating the fair but I think we pretty
much know that it's not fair
um because I want to talk a little bit
about your career if I may um misheard
you're with a chair and the pro
Chancellor of the University of
Manchester you're a senior uh senior
independent director and remuneration
committee chair of Ordnance survey a
non-executive director of UK strategy
commander and an independent member of
the remunerations committee of some
Edmunds College Cambridge there was a
lot of word independent there I felt so
when um you're called well when he says
your processor rigged and the idea that
you are independent is farcical and what
would you say to that and that was said
by Andy Prendergast of the GMB
I think quite a lot about the issue of
Independence and how you actually make
it happen so I wonder if it's helpful
talking about that yes very helpful
um so one of the ways in which you're
independent is you're not part of it
you're not
part part of the organization is there
any of the organizations involved we're
not part of those so we are technically
independent
um the other way in which you're
independent and this is one of the
things I I think about quite a lot in
relation to invent is is you have to
um take information from a very broad
range of sources
so some people I think see Independence
as
has been completely apart from something
you actually have to know and understand
something in order to make judgments
about it
um and one of the challenges one of the
reasons you have term limits for example
in that you know if you spend too long
with something you get to know it too
well and you can't be independent from
it but you do have to know it fairly
well
um and so one of the ways in which we're
independent is we take and we take very
seriously evidence from all the parties
involved and we also choose to get
evidence from a wide range of of other
independent sources
um so uh we'll get economic evidence we
get from think tanks and
um and we look at all of that evidence
with um with care
um and and thoughtfulness and we look at
it together so we have different
perspectives on that
um and then the third way in which you
exercise Independence is is by making
decisions
so just my last question I just want you
to confirm if you met that you you're
you're operating to the same terms and
condition as that were set in 2007 and
when the body was was set up
um and again to see if you would like to
comment on the fact that you were called
human Shields by the uh tuc's um Paul
Novak
well so it says you're operating the
same terms and conditions
um now that then you than um like you
were in 2007. I just want to make sure
that's confirmed because that's what
I've picked up today in the notes say
you're operating to the same terms and
conditions that was set in 2007.
um do you mean terms of reference yes
sorry terms of reference if you want to
comment on the terms of reference
because they apply to you I think most
of the people sorry forgivable in terms
of reference
so yes broadly the same in terms of
reference have been operating then yes
since that time and each year there is
also an independent sorry there's a
remit and and just coming back to um
your points about independence I think
the point is that that all of the
members of the review body are appointed
through the uh an open and transparent
process and are overseen by the the
public appointments committee so um and
they're all appointed
because of their backgrounds and they're
not representing for example a trade
Union we have a member of that
background on there we have members from
all different groups but they're not
representing their those particular
groups
thank you very much
very very interesting thank you for that
call you are acutely aware of how
political a position that you are
finding yourself in even though you are
clearly not political neither of you are
but you know you have one of the most
important jobs in the in the country
right now which is why there's so much
so much interest in this and you know
some of those quotes that my colleague
has just read out I mean they're pretty
horrible they're pretty harsh aren't
they they're pretty horrible and harsh
to say that you're effectively
Stooges Tory Stooges just doing the
government's bidding and it must be
quite annoying
considering you are somebody of
independent stature with a very
impressive
CV and work that you've that you've done
and continue to do I mean it must be
quite annoying
it's not things indeed we we have and
it's gonna
sound that we have a PR we have a
privilege in having all this information
and pulling it together and then laying
it before parliament in a completely
open way
um and so we really do show a working
out
um in as you say some detail
um and I think that what we've tried to
do during this process because we're
obviously now in the in the process for
2023 is just do what we do and carry on
with assessing the evidence listening to
staff in trust which is what we've been
doing over this last few months
um and um and keeping focused on the
work
maybe some of the camera Crews that
spend a lot of time in emergency
department should spend some time
following you
don't answer that
um right James Morrison so I said I
think I heard you say that one of the
processes that you go through is seeking
consensus on the Judgment you've come to
in terms of pay
um
how do you go about trying to get
consensus
with the eight pay everybody members
well we we work very carefully together
at every stage
um so we we read all the papers and
there are thousands of pictures of
papers together with page sent together
um we um interview everyone together and
eat you know get key stages we check
understanding how how does everyone feel
about this water people's concerns where
are the key areas we need to develop
further
um so by the time we get to the stage
that we have um we've finished our
taking while evidence we then assembled
all the evidence in one place
um because natural you know that goes in
a reasonably coherent form in the report
um
and then we we as I said we work on the
themes together so that by the time we
actually get to make our recommendations
we we have developed a collective view
about the the various different issues
and we we then have a process of coming
to the same view on on key issues like
the number like
um the the issues on which we think
there needs to be more developed work so
you will be aware that two years ago and
last year we asked for
um a review of the banding of nurses
midwives
um because we were concerned that it's a
very long time since that banding was
set
um the in interim nursing's become a
graduate profession
um uh we were concerned that it was a
long time since anyone had looked at
whether the banding accurately reflected
the complexities of job as it's done
today so you know that's the kind of
thing that would emerge as we're
developing our
um as we're developing our consensus
because Mr Morris's point about
consensus are you like the bank of
England in that you have a decision to
make as a group and then you vote and
you publish where the balance was within
the group or do you do exercise
Collective responsibility we we come to
a decision together okay we don't vote
and if it was a
she do you show your workers out in
terms of how people dissented or
otherwise before you get or is it like
cabinet in 30 years time we'll find out
we we come to a consensus we do come to
a collective view or we have done yeah I
mean again I can't speak for other pay
review bodies but that's what we do and
you don't leak interesting Lucy good
morning
um are you still working towards an
April 23 deadline I said hat in the
remit so can I ask has the government
provided you with
um the evidence that you need yet no no
and how is that then going to impact on
your process and will it actually delay
your findings
um I wonder if this is a good moment to
talk I'll come back to the question
definitely but I wanted to give mention
about timing
um because you would have seen in um
last year's been the 21 report and in
2022 report that we set out our concerns
about the timing of the of the process
as it has evolved so
um historic practice traditional
practice um has been that the um pay of
your body would get a roommate letter in
um in September which allowed us then to
do our work
um so that we could report in the early
part of the year
um and and that had two benefits one it
meant that agenda change staff got their
pay award when it was due on the 1st of
April
um or there was an opportunity to do
that and secondly that the um our
findings could influence
um uh budget setting and thinking about
the balance of investment of pay in Pay
versus
um other things you might invest in
infrastructure and Technology
Etc
um in the last two years our remit
letters come in at the end of November
end of November which sets us back a
long way
and means that it's impossible for us to
report in time for any award due to be
paid on the 1st of April
um and for any information we give to
inform ministers as they're planning
their budget so I think that that's a
it's a specific timing concern which we
set out now two years running and and
I'm really hoping that going forward
um we can we can bring that timetable
forward
um it was due to be submitted on the
11th of January the government's so the
government's evidence it was due on the
11th of January um a couple of days
before a few days before that I wrote to
to the minister just to um
reiterate the importance of this
deadline and he wrote back
um straight away confirming that he
understood the importance of the
deadline
um we have we had pretty much by the
deadline actually we had some really
um really timely evidence this year
um so we've been working with the
evidence we've got we have oral evidence
that starts next week
um
It's Not Unusual for evidence to come
late as I said this year it's been very
timely in previous years we've expressed
in our report a number of times real
gratitude to parties who have been very
flexible about timing
um uh so that we've been able to absorb
some evidence that has been late
and we're carrying on working
um with our current academic table and
we're not at the moment planning to put
anything back
April 23 you will be ready to report
we are aiming to report by the end of
April 23. yes
if the government doesn't I mean it's
February tomorrow
if the government doesn't provide the
relevant evidence surely it's going to
impact on your process
I'm still expecting evidence of the
government
um if it doesn't come we'll deal with
that we'll cross that bridge when we
come to it okay and I've got one one
further question if I may
um is it really realistic for the
government to expect the prb to take
account of wider economic circumstances
such as inflation I mean do you have the
expertise within the organization to be
able to factor that into your
deliberations
um we we have two economists who are
everybody members uh one is a labor
market Economist another is a very
experienced um General Economist and
they make a very substantial
contribution to our work
thanks Lucy uh I'm I'm just I mean I saw
it in the notes beforehand that the
government hadn't responded by the time
of this session so 21 days after the
deadline that was due I I'm astonished
that that you've been able to confirm
that today I mean to having spent
all the holiday season since the
roommate letter effective Philly
standing behind the pair of your body to
then not respond to it by the date that
you asked for I mean that must
you say we hope to hear from the
government but I mean
but you don't have to hear from the
government do you I mean they don't have
to they don't have to respond to you I
mean this must be intolerable and what
would your message be to the Secretary
of State who I assure you we will be
asking this this afternoon what would
your message be to get get a skates on I
presume
we're carrying on with our work
um we have already written to um the
minister to express my concerns about
the deadline
um we
we're carrying on doing what we do
um and uh we will
um
we'll we're being as flexible as we can
be in order to um to make sure we get
our report done on time
you're missing a it's like saying we're
making chocolate without cocoa beans
isn't it
have had treasury evidence yes
right
so it's not that we have no evidence the
government we just don't have evidence
from the Department of Health
right we'll take it up uh Rachel must go
next
and clearly the department provides
information on some of the challenges
facing the NHS at this time and I think
it's fair to say that
um with the Recruitment and Retention
issues and also the issues of motivating
staff which is one of the matters that
the pay-per-view body has to look at is
that this is
um the most challenged time since agenda
for change has been put in place
you've got the balances right when you
are seeing
NHS staff saying that they can't
maintain their services anymore because
of attention issues there are equipment
challenges ml is at an all-time low
it's a difficult balance and you'll
you'll see that we we set out our
concerns about Recruitment and Retention
in the report you'll also see that we
we said that we would be prepared at any
time uh to look at
um Recruitment and Retention
um uh issue Recruitment and Retention
premium in the event that
um the situation worsened
um
it was a difficult balance
it is a difficult balance
also we've got the most volatile
economic time as well and just to look
at the 22-23 year report and if we think
about the remits letter coming out in
November
um since we've experienced Energy prices
rising we've seen inflation going into
double digits and the cost of
Commodities Rising sharply too do you
think the time lag has had an impact on
why there is a dispute currently overpay
that's a timeline to your point of
reporting and clearly
um the the situation we're in now
we were very concerned about inflation
for obvious reasons we were doing our
last report
um
we had we had a remit report in that in
that year but our concerns about
inflation together with with other
issues
um were significantly influenced our
decision to to recommend a flat cash
award last year so that those are on the
lower pay
um points uh would have
um more resilience in relation to
inflation because we were particularly
concerned about the inflation impact on
those
um on the lower pay points
um so um
that's why we focused the recommendation
on on those areas
um
we've now got a recommendation to
prepare for this year and in doing that
we'll look at what's happened to pay
um from from all kinds of employers in
the intervening time
in the night that clearly over the last
13 years has been significant regression
in pay for NHS professionals and and we
know that across the board nurse was
saying
um 19 is what they were seeking
initially with the resolution of the
current dispute and we know across the
board that there has been significant
loss in the real value of those jobs how
do you look at historic loss with
comparison to the rest of the economy
and whether or not the remit letter is
restraining your opportunity to address
that disparity and particularly noting
that that has now led to a significant
accumulation
which has brought about this dispute
which is ongoing at the moment
okay as I said we're asked to make a
recommendation in a one year
um and and they're in under
considerations we have to um work with
what we do try and do
um is inform longer term thinking
um in government about the investment in
pay and the case for that
um uh hence
um uh concerns about nurses pay for
example
um
there have been
investments in the agenda for change pay
spine over the last six years in
particular so you'll be aware that
three-year deal
um awarded or put above inflation
investment into the agenda change pay
spine over three years and then we also
did that in 2021
um for the reasons we've talked about we
recommended a flat cash award
um again
significantly related to inflation
levels a lot of concerns about those in
2022 so there has been some brown made
up
um but more recently that's become more
challenged
do you believe it's a pay-per-view body
that you clearly handed a remit letter
which has real significance about the
scope of what you can recommend
do you believe that you're restrained in
the recommendation that you would want
to provide because of that remit letter
so
um in some ways you'll handle the
envelope and you've been asked to sort
out the distribution but actually you
don't have sufficient scope to say the
real economic
benefits that we could bring to the
wider NHS to The Wider economy if we
could
perhaps not have that cap being placed
on you and actually to make that form of
recommendation could be a way of looking
at how you can address the real value
and or the real loss of value in the the
pay which NHS staff receive
I think they're I'd answer that in two
parts
um one um we obviously didn't see it as
an absolute constraint because we
recommended more than the government
said they could afford and that was the
reasons that we said
um
we we do try to set out the case for
investment in pay
and we will continue to do that
um the the
there is a constraint created by the
amount of money
that the government say they have
available but we set the other
considerations
alongside that and in the last two years
have recommended more than the
government say they have available
would you acknowledge however that that
simply hasn't been enough in the light
of the recruitment retention and low
morale that we're now seeing being
displayed and that if urgent
intervention isn't made in this coming
process that we could be in an even more
challenged place in the NHS with regards
to Recruitment and Retention than we
have been up to this point where we've
got over 133 and a half thousand
vacancies
gonna sound slightly annoying but I'm
not going to comment on what what our
recommendations are going to be this
year
okay
Paulette Hamilton
good morning
I am looking through the notes
um I saw a little bit about the nuffield
trust they did a Blog and they set out
that the recommendations really how the
pay review body could improve they also
went on to say that the pay review body
needed to be more explicit so it gave 11
recommendations but it also said the pay
review body needed to be more explicit
if any afford if there were any
affordability envelope restrictions that
you had so my first question is with
this in mind is there anything
um the NHS pay review body can do to
strengthen its independence from
governments
um I've I've read the same enough for
the reporters and he just come out so I
haven't but I haven't had a chance to do
is talk about it with a pair of your
body members
um so I can't comment um widely they
interestingly they do pick up the timing
point that we've just discussed earlier
which is an issue that I have taught to
members about
um I'm wondering if David if you
wouldn't mind picking up the nuffield
thing because because as I said we
haven't had a chance to talk about it
when you're right that's something the
review body will have a look at and
those are often often views about how
the review buddies could work and how
how they could could change and I think
I mean what's interesting is some of the
things they've said that should be done
are things that that are done by the
review body so uh for example it talks
about the review body needing to have
access to research
um and the way that it works at the
moment is that we have a Secretariat
um which includes uh policy analysts and
um
statisticians and economists who provide
advice so you know during the round they
will be advice on things like
International recruitment of nurses
comparisons of pay of the NHS with with
other workers and that's all part of
what what comes in and indeed in the
reports you can see how it it explicitly
looks at how things like you know the
top and the bottom of the nurses pay
scale how that is has has fared in
comparison with inflation and the like
but also beyond that we if the review
body wants to do another analysis our
ome can commission this on their behalf
so we commission external research so
relatively recently have commissioned
research on behalf of all the review
bodies looking at
apprenticeships and how that the impact
of apprenticeships on Recruitment and
Retention because I think that's
apprenticeships is something that's
quite important for for professions such
as the NHS and indeed the um
we have recently just commissioned a
project on looking at nurse turnover so
that's one of the things that the review
buddy does to at the moment and as I
said um you know we'll look at it to see
what says ultimately the the terms of
reference for the review body it is for
government to look at these things but
um but as I say some of these things and
you know the appointment of the review
body we talked about how they're
independent how they come from different
backgrounds many of these things in
there I think are things that the
current review body does but the timing
is is the issue that that Philippa
mentioned which I think is a you know is
an important thing to help help
um people understand the recommendation
to the point that one of your colleagues
mentioned earlier I think you know that
the earlier the the nearer that
recommendations can be made
um uh can can be made to the time of uh
when pay is due and the government can
decide on that and people get the pay in
their payback at the time that it's due
the better chance that these things will
be accepted by
um uh by people getting the pay Rises so
I think there are you know there are
good things in there to to look at
and my second question I've heard
everything you've said this morning and
um I appreciate everything you've said
um I'll I'll talk to you Philippa but my
concern is that over a number of years
although there are many people that feed
into the pay review body the
government's voice seems to be the only
voice that is truly been heard and for
me the next question is do you feel the
way the Paint Body operates is truly
open and transparent is it truly a fair
system for our health workers and is the
outdated
the process which I've I've talked about
um we go through to gather evidence from
all parties the way in which we consider
evidence the way in which we bring in
evidence from other other places
um
feels like a very independent process
we don't agree with the government
um on affordability considerations and
have recommended on occasions
um and have recommended higher levels
because we haven't accepted their
affordability constraints
um we we listen hard to a very very wide
range of voices
um and we
come up with a body of evidence that
informs debate generally we come up with
a number in any one year and with with
what I hope are a series of
recommendations about investment in pay
that
that are heard
I'll tell you the reason why I say all
of that and I'm not having a go I really
am not but
um Mr Hunt the the health secretary that
became the member of this committee you
recommended a rise I think back in 2014
I'm desperately trying to find it and
he disagreed it just did nothing
it just didn't happen so if the even
though the government say you're
independent they put the constraints
down they set the the limits if they
don't agree with it it just doesn't
happen so that's why I'm challenging
just how independent and transparent
this process truly is
sorry sorry oh yeah
so we make an independent recommendation
the government doesn't have to accept it
our recommendation is independent they
don't have to accept it it's their
decision
and just on that you're writing into you
know but but since 2010 I think there's
been one recommendation that's been
turned down by governments and you're
right and that was in both the UK
government in 2014.
thank you thank you Jay on advisors
advise ministers decide yeah principle
that is consistent yes right and that's
it that's our brief to make a
recommendation okay so Dr Caroline
Johnson and then Toyota
sure and that is assessed by the ddrb
which are not here today but are one of
the independent uh payment bodies um
so just to clarify a point first that
Lucy raised um will this delay in
receipt of evidence from the Department
of Health mean that your recommendations
for the uplift and pay received in April
will not be received in April or will
they not received in April anyway
because the process is uh starting too
late as you described
um the process is starting uh later than
previous practice and on the basis of
starting at the end of November we
um we
took the view that we could deliver the
report by the end of April
um
uh we still haven't had evidence in the
government we are still planning to
deliver our report by the end of April
that pay that is for pay from the next
financial year isn't it so it's already
not going to received an April's pay
rise as it should as it should be
so that's a meaning that you're actually
behind the curve already not saying it's
your fault but it is behind the curve
already
as I said
um for for us to be able to give
um give the recommendation uh ahead of
the curve we would need to start the
process in September
okay thank you um
the other thing I wanted to ask you
about was the um the agenda for change
package as a whole so we see on the news
the GMB talking about ambulance workers
pay and we hear about the RCN talking
about nurses pay as though they were
negotiating for all of these groups as
separate groups as though they were paid
on different pay scales but they're not
um so um as we see there are challenges
in retention recruitment that does
differ between the different groups
whether that be ambulance workers
whether that be nurses whether that be
manager supporters cleaners whatever
um do you think it would be
easier and are you constrained from
doing
um making recommendations for specific
working groups so would you be able to
give the nurses a bit more or is that
not possible within the constraints of
your IFC
um say to your right there are um in in
England there are uh one and a quarter
million staff on agenda for change of
whom 350 000 are nurses
um so another 900 000 are not
um
uh and
um uh there is a mechanism that allows
you to
um to
recommend Recruitment and Retention
Premier within agenda for change uh for
specific staff groups and we we actually
because
um we thought it'd be helpful we set out
I think in our 2020 report other
considerations we'd be looking for
um uh to establish recruit and retention
premium so you can do that
does it thinking the other question I've
got is observed over time working on the
wards
that once a nurse becomes a senior nurse
working on what that's a hard job he or
she is working long hours they work in
Christmas bank holidays on sociable
times of the week
and
they can be quite an attractive option
to move into a better paid job in a more
managerial or supervisory role that
doesn't require such an essential hours
and it seemed to me for a long time that
it would be do it for better for patient
care if we could incentivize
um nurses who've done let all those
fabulous clinical skills and who really
are the nurses which the more Junior
nurses are able to look up to and learn
from to stay working on those Wards with
additional monies is that something that
you're able to look at
what is this yes
it's really interesting managerial Works
seem to be worth more because it gets a
higher ban actually what we hear from
staff from from the party at the moment
is is is a different situation we we
hear concerns about progression
and about abilities to progress and so
people saying that actually
um the rewards for progression are
insufficient
um so that's I mean we've we've covered
this in the report
um uh
so one of our concerns actually and when
we were thinking about
um banding review is does the current
banding and the way in which the bands
work for example the gaps literally the
gaps between the bands in fact
um create enough of an incentive enough
of
um uh enough reward for progression I
guess it's the same information really
because there's it progression between
bands five six and seven yeah or are you
talking about between seven and eight
because it seems that's the point at
which the clinical work largely stops
and actually I could agree that it seems
that the rewards for being the nurse in
charge of the ward on a night at three
o'clock in the morning perhaps aren't as
great as they should be in terms of
progression but then there's a real
incentive to move from that position
into a nine to five moment of Friday
um you know office based role really
interesting it's one of the areas where
we get very little that that what
happens to Band-Aids one of the areas
where we get very little evidence from
the parties and actually we've called
this year for more evidence because we
think it's an underdeveloped area thank
you my other question is about how you
measure things over time
so when I was I was looking at some of
my junior doctor payslips
um and it's how you if I was to compare
the pay that I received as a junior
doctor
pay that a junior doctor might receive
now I might think I was comparing the
same thing but in some respects I am in
some respects I'm not because at that
time there was quite a lot of work went
into trying to comply with European
working time directives and improve
hours so it was not uncommon for me as a
junior doctor to work 16 or even 24
hours in a shift to work seven
consecutive 39 night shift and to work
21 days in a row none of which is
allowed under the current rate of ending
and it was common to work more than 58
hours in a week as an average and now
you can't work more than 48. so if I
compare the pay now with the pay then
I'm not comparing the same thing how do
you account for over when we're looking
over time are those those changes in
pain pain conditions as well as pay
because those condition changes make
working life better but they do also
cost the government whoever's paying the
bill a lot of money
um so the agenda for change pay spine
has
um has nine
um bands on it
um and those have points in between them
um and jobs are evaluated according to
that pay spine so there's a
um
a way in which jobs are assessed to look
at their size and then they're put on
various different bandings
um as I said we've asked for some uh
analysis to be done to check that those
are still up to date because jobs do
change they become more complicated and
some become simpler and things do change
and what we hear from uh from staff in
hospitals and we hear from our the
parties is that
um that generally a feeling is that more
work could be done to continually to
assess whether jobs are bounded at the
right level
and actually to access whether jobs
abandoned at the right level
um so I think that process does happen
um but I I generally I think the party's
views I think there would probably be a
consensus on this is that they that work
could be done more actively
as as well as well as that
because I could say well
paid I don't need to pay 30 000 pounds
for doing some job
um that was 58 hours a week in arduous
hours and now I'd be paid 32 000 pounds
a year and make the numbers it was
random
um for doing a job which is 48 hours a
week so essentially I've had quite a
substantial pay rise in that period
because my early rate has gone up quite
a lot but the actual headline take game
has not really gone up so how do you
look at how do you look at what what is
being done for the same amount of money
over time when working conditions I was
actually made some quite a big amount of
the um clients
I'm not sure whether what you're
describing in relation to doctor's pay
would also be applied in a different end
of a change staff who tends don't look
at working conditions we
um well uh we we look at
um
yeah
we don't look at detailed time
conditions hours of work for example
um I no one has
um
no one has flagged that as a significant
concern
um uh and I think that the that as Jobs
change as they become more or less
pressurized that will be reflected in
the way in which individual trusts
um think about the size of the job
so if a job becomes easier to do
less less stressful less technically
difficult over time a trust will decide
that it's no longer a band seven job
it's a van six job for example so
individual trusts will assess the weight
of an individual job and put it in a
particular banding
thank you doctor
thank you chair but nothing in this
world is perfect now you've been
chairing the board for six years now is
there anything in the process in which
you think that it needs to be adapted
improved or even just scrapped in order
to make it more efficient and to make it
better value for money for both staff
and taxpayers I missed the very
beginning of your questions I just said
nothing is perfect all right sorry
um so the the pay review body process
itself
um I thought the um nuffield report was
really interesting actually
um uh and I think I would kind of
welcome the um the thoughtful way in
which they went about
um making their accommodation says David
said some of the things I think we we do
do
um
I'm always you mentioned it's quite a
long report
um uh and I'm always looking for ways of
making it
um uh more effective in doing what it it
does
um
we we look
um each year at our timetable to look at
whether we could compress it it's a
challenge because of that process of
needing to be open and everyone else to
be able to see everyone else's evidence
and you know so um uh it's a challenge
to compress the timetable but we we do
continue to look at that and actually uh
this year we we have tried to make it as
compressed as possible one of the other
challenges actually to the point about
timing Learners of evidence is that you
can press it too much and you can't
afford for anyone without their evidence
and then things get very difficult very
fast so
um it's something we think about
continually to be honest and we're
always trying to borrow best practice
from each other and learn from each
other
in terms of areas um that you think
about in terms of improving what YouTube
was about have you ever considered
having more autonomy in terms of being
able to decide for example staff benefit
for some of the staff within the gender
for change so for example if I worked
for I don't know a normal company as
part of my staff pay negotiation staff
benefits it's a conversation in terms of
what you offer because that's also
calculated as part of guests pay
indirectly
do you think it's beneficial that you
have the powers to be able to recommend
some of that within the NHS
we make a number of observations
um and we talk a lot about total reward
um the parties are probably quite bored
of me talking about a total reward
um because it's not
what you get paid is incredibly
important but there are a lot of other
elements to the to the the working
experience from things like benefits
pensions through to how you feel about
your work and what you do
um and so we do make a number of
observations uh about terms and
conditions uh in our reports so
flexibility I think is is probably the
example I would focus on flexibility in
relation to pensions and flexibility in
relation to working hours both of which
are areas where more flexibility would
would allow the the overall NHS pay
package to be more compelling
um and you know we've set both those
things out in some detail in the report
any other areas that you benefits that
you feel like NHS staff
would benefit from from having in terms
of I'm trying to make the job more
competitive compared to other sectors
what staff tell us when we talk to them
is that they
um
they they feel under a lot of time
pressure
um and that their working experience is
challenging
um they they talk about wanting quite
practical things in their workplace
about wanting space to you know to take
time out
access to healthy food
and and clarity about when they're when
they're working overtime and being paid
for overtime so some of those quite
important things are things we we make
comments on in the report
because they are very important to staff
and and in some acute settings where
things are very stressful
they don't always they don't always get
delivered
okay
we want to move on to
the gender for pay scale how it works
practically so obviously you've got
outside of London waiters go and you've
got inside of London yeah
but the reality is is that outside of
London is not blank in terms of the cost
of living in different areas it's it's
not the same if you leave if you live
down south most likely your cost of
living is going to be a bit more than
somebody who lives up north
as you make recommendations to
government is that being factored in in
terms of
um how that impacts Recruitment and
Retention within different regions and
their ability to be able to retain staff
as well yeah so
um the NHS operates hcas
um which is a high area supplement
essentially which which focuses on
London and immediate surrounds
um and there are the parties have
described a number of challenges with
hcast particularly to do with areas that
are actually very expensive
um and you know the occasionally you get
trusts that actually border areas where
that you know different parts of a trust
pay have to pay people so um it's a
challenge
um uh we um we so from time to time peer
review bodies are asked to look at
specific issues
and that's an example of something that
on occasions I would imagine a pay
everybody might be asked to look at we
said last year that um given that there
was still quite a lot of settling down
um
post-covered as where people were
working and living
um that maybe now wasn't the time to do
it but I think we would be always be
willing to um to look at hcas
um to see whether it was still
um fit for purpose as an example to a
a new nurse would earn in the rest of
the country just a 27 and a half
thousand in in London they'd earn 30 to
33 000 so quite you know and there's
quite a big difference but it is a it is
a concern for many of the parties
involved
um and and has been as it is for some
time
it is a major concern because if you
live in an area like Chichester the cost
of living there is significantly more
than if you lived
in I want to say somewhere in Yorkshire
and given the fact that both members of
Staff will start with about 20 million
I'm seeing Rachel shake your head that
it might be different just to pick a
random area
you know just to be able to keep up with
the cost of living full staff that is
you know quite significant I just want
to move to one last area which is how
you consider NHS transformation projects
when trying when putting forward
recommendation for staff Recruitment and
Retention is that something that's
factored in in terms of how the NHS is
going to be able to get the necessary
skill set needed for it to be able to
achieve some of the transformation
projects that it wants to
yeah it really is one of the things that
I found very challenging a couple of
years ago is when Chief Executives who
come and talk to us in oral evidence I
should have mentioned one of the good
things about oral evidence we get trust
you for detectives can come and talk to
us one of the chief Executives said you
know I've got I'm I'm so focused on
um Workforce issues trying to have
enough people that I don't actually have
time to think about the transformation
things that would improve situations so
I think
um uh um there is a direct relationship
between
um uh the the having enough work enough
people in your hospital to do the work
needs to be done and your ability to
think ahead and move and transform
things so I think there is a
relationship between those two things
would you consider that in your report
when you're making consider that
relationship in your report when you are
making recommendations
in what way in terms of so for example
I'm thinking about the fact that NHS is
doing their digital transformation
project yeah and that is going to cost a
lot and that's going to require
recruiting iot staff who are highly
Technical and the reality is in this
country regardless of what industry you
look at their pay is relatively
competitive so that means as every trust
looks at how to implement their digital
transformation they're going to be
looking at how to recruit the best but
also within the agenda for skill
um
pathway so do you consider some of those
challenges when looking at
recommendations so that each just is
able to achieve their transformation
projects absolutely so
um a couple of years ago we were
specifically asked to look at
um at it staff and
whether the offer was was competitive
and whether there was a case for a
recruitment and retention Premier
um we we didn't get evidence from the
parties to suggest that there was there
was a requirement for recruitment to
attention Premier
but we continue to you'll be aware that
NHS
X I think as it has now been um
incorporated into NHS England and when
we when we assess the evidence from NHS
England
um those kind of questions are exactly
the kind of questions we would discuss
okay so we spoke to them a couple of
weeks ago I think they did say that
there were quite a few challenges with
that so it's something to bear in mind
for my next the review is done but as
you can imagine the line the landscape
has changed so much since covid where
there's been an over-reliance across all
Industries on just Tech professionals
but that's just one example there are
other professionals within the gender
for straight change structure in which
actually their payment will be as
competitive
within compared to other sectors within
the public domain check okay thank you
the Thai's final thought
um just a couple of things from from me
before we we close if from from what
we've heard I mean it's a really
excellent
questions and it seems like your work is
quite similar to ours and that you open
inquiries and take oral evidence and
then produce report
um
if the pay-per-view body didn't exist
it would have to be invented wouldn't it
I like that David you keep getting this
Hospital past
but but isn't it isn't it the case I
mean the reason let me just let me just
expand on the reason behind my question
is that you know we keep hearing and
I've been on media with with other
speakers from from unions and from other
parties and you know the refrain is
Minister should get in the room and
negotiate
and I don't know what that means
I mean does that mean the end of the pay
review body because you know does it
mean a uh
a dismissal of you and effect well
collective bargaining what if it didn't
exist wouldn't you have to invent it I
mean I think the observation I would
make is that you know these review
bodies have been created by uh
governments of both parties over over a
number of years and I think that
suggests they must be doing something
that
something that works over time
um because
no one has found probably a better way
of of setting pay for large groups of of
the public sector so you know it's not
my job to decide or recommend on what's
the right way of doing it but my
observation would be that the process
has endured over time obviously it's had
it's had tricky periods um
it for a review body process to work
effectively you need both parties to be
part of it and these things have changed
over time so on that
you know and this sort of follows on
from some of the questions from some of
my colleagues here is that you know see
the pay review body process needs some
repair doesn't it I mean I think you
need to go to the repair shop because
the confidence right now you know your
body has taken a beating in recent
months from
some some opposition MPS uh from some
government MPS from the trade unions
from members of the media
people who haven't read your report
um people who have read your report but
it's taken a beating as a process in
recent months so much so that the trade
unions are now saying I appreciate there
are a few who are saying we're not
playing
um and therefore the process has got a
it's got a credibility problem
what would be your suggestion as to how
the repair shop can help
you're gonna pass that back to me
um
we're going to carry on doing what we do
at the moment
I'm going to go carry on with our work
and we're going to carry on producing
our report
and if there is an opportunity
for government to look at the terms of
reference of peer review bodies which
haven't I don't think been reviewed
since 2007 so maybe it's a moment
um I think there's some thoughtful work
and the Northfield Foundation has begun
some thoughtful work on on
how you might develop it seems to me
that something that hasn't been
developed since 2007 might want a review
um
okay these are these it's a challenging
time at the moment for everybody
um and I think our
the contribution I can best make at this
stage is to carry on with the work of
creating a recommendation uh and a set
of observations uh for this year
and then it's a challenging time yeah it
certainly is because obviously there are
ongoing pay disputes about the current
year that we're in how could the
government end current strikes
that is a matter for the government
well it's a matter for government to do
it but what would be the process by
which they would do it because they'd
have to trample over your work for the
current report
and undo their acceptance
of your work wouldn't they
I wouldn't make any assumptions about
what the government might do I think it
was probably worth saying that that
um as when I first started doing this
work there was a three-year deal in
place was a which was as a result of
negotiations through the staff Council
between the government and the unions
um so that's not unprecedented would you
like to have seen that put in place
for this year and the following two
there are challenges with three-year
deals yeah sometimes circumstances
change like Wars in Europe
um and and a lot has been a high levels
inflation so things change so I think
that it's not you know there was a
particular set of circumstances and and
um an agreement that additional money
needed to be put in the agenda for
change pay spine and and a series of
things over which
um the employers and the unions could
agree uh and so it's it's not it's I I
I'm carrying on with our work
um and I think that we will
um we will do our best to make a
recommendation uh
not just for uh award this year but also
for the areas where we think there are
ongoing concerns and where
um
the case for investment in pay as
opposed to investment in technology or
infrastructure is an important one to
make okay then just finally for me and
then Paul blumford is going to close
the NHS Workforce strategy is much
talked of and uh you know we expect that
to come in the very near future have you
been asked as an NHS pay review body
given how important pay is to
recruitment retention to Workforce have
you been asked for your input into that
strategy
not specifically no
okay
it's Bloomfield
sure I just wanted to follow up on a
point we've discussed in in a sense
relates to your last questions which is
about a broken bit of the system and
your reference to inflation
because at the time that you were
getting your submissions for the uh 22 3
review
inflation was running of about five
percent
at the time six months later the
announcement was made
it was doubled at just over 10 percent
after a decade in which pay restraint
has kind of been grudgingly accepted
that was probably the straw that broke
the camel's back that mismatch
at that point in time when the
announcement was made
now do you think the
best way of dealing with that at that
point could have been
for you to be given the opportunity to
look again at your recommendation
or do you think that the government
should have taken your recommendation
in that new context and made a separate
decision breaking with your your yeah
that really is a decision for the
government
okay sure answer Philip heard uh the NHS
part of your body thank you so much for
coming in David Frye from the business
energy industrial strategy Department
thank you so much for being part of this
topical session it has been very very
interesting and I know there's a lot of
interest outside as well as inside
Parliament thank you for your time order
order
the proceeding has ended